y
[Música]
en el áfrica sub-sahariana hay una nueva
fiebre del oro
una fiebre que atrae a todos los
migrantes la cantidad de minas de oro
artesanales se ha disparado
[Música]
y malí se ha establecido como el
principal centro de compra de oro de los
países argelia nos
un auge aurífero que escapa del control
de los estados y despierta la avidez
creciente de los grupos armados hay
sudaneses eritreos hay no sé miseria no
porque unas veces todas las
nacionalidades vienen aquí porque para
nosotros en el islam lo que está en el
subsuelo le pertenece a todos
una producción imposible de cuantificar
pero que opera a cielo abierto
[Música]
estas pepitas que llegan a los locales
de bamako provienen de toda el áfrica
sub-sahariana se mezclan y después se
funden en las refinerías que funcionan
discretamente bajo los techos de un gran
mercado
[Música]
el origen del oro es imposible de
rastrear y la mayoría de estos lingotes
serán enviados a los emiratos árabes
unidos
dubai importador o con una simple
factura
se entra a dubai con una factura
comercial y se declara se pagan nueve
dólares americanos
a una cuota fija en aduana y el oro
entra a dubai donde está el verdadero
escándalo aquí o allá va
dubai se ha convertido en el principal
destino de la producción de oro ilegal e
ilegal del continente africano
las refinerías de los emiratos árabes
unidos- blanquean el oro sucio
proveniente de las zonas de conflicto
de las minas ilegales del sahel a los
rascacielos de dubai nuestro reportaje
permite entender mejor cómo está
cambiando el sector aurífero mundial
[Música]
la investigación empieza en sudáfrica
donde la casa contra los explotadores
ilegales de oro hace parte del día a día
las unidades de élite especializadas
hacen operativos regulares en las minas
artesanales ilegales
l
es un trabajo ilegal pero muy popular el
oro es el mejor medio para financiar las
actividades criminales su precio aumenta
constantemente es transportado y re
vendido en cualquier parte se puede
mezclar con facilidad para los
sudafricanos no se trata de un micro
tráfico
[Música]
y
está en lo que llamamos los amas aman
los amas amas o en mineros ilegales
es una palabra en su lo que significa
prueba tu suerte o haz algo de la nada
pero en todas maneras no somos ingenuos
cuando lidiamos con este tipo de cosas
sabemos que aunque se trate de los amas
amas o de traficantes de oro a niveles
más altos todo se inscribe dentro del
plano más grande de la criminalidad del
financiamiento del terrorismo porque en
todos los rincones del mundo los métodos
son los mismos grupos criminales
transnacionales al igual que las
organizaciones terroristas usan el
comercio del oro para financiar todas
sus operaciones
el general cada es el jefe de los
halcones esta rama de la policía
sudafricana se especializa en el crimen
organizado en sudáfrica el tráfico de
oro se ha vuelto una prioridad porque el
país no solo es productor de oro sino
que se ha convertido en uno de los ejes
centrales del tráfico en el continente
los servicios del general interceptan
regularmente grandes cargamentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 31 de diciembre de 2020 un avión
privado que venía desde madagascar
aterrizó en johannesburgo al revisar las
maletas de los pasajeros que debían
llegar hasta dubai los funcionarios de
la aduana descubrieron más de 73 kilos
de oro en bruto los pasajeros le
mostraron a las autoridades sudafricanas
las facturas de una empresa llamada sky
gold registrada en mali el equivalente a
3 millones de dólares en mercancía no
había sido declarado
[Música]
los sospechosos fueron inmediatamente
llevados ante la justicia
eran de nacionalidad malgache las
autoridades de antananarivo pidieron su
extradición y reclamaron la mercancía
porque la explotación de oro está
prohibida en la isla desde 2020 pero
primero debían probar que el oro había
sido extraído en madagascar
madagascar acepta los documentos de malí
que confirman la compra del oro
no está ante madagascar afirma que de
los 73 kilos de oro sólo 3 kilos se
compraron más
los representantes de sky gold habían
pasado por el aeropuerto de bamako unos
meses antes pero es difícil saber
realmente cuántos lingotes habían
llevado desde malí el expediente de la
investigación contiene documentos
contradictorios
y
i
un primer formulario señala que los 73
kilos fueron correctamente declarados el
logro estaba destinado a la empresa
partía en dubai
pero en un segundo documento en el que
también aparece el sello de las aduanas
de malí la empresa sky gold solo declaró
tres kilos de oro en bruto
en un mundo donde las facturas falsas
son moneda corriente la investigación de
la justicia sudafricana continúa
para tratar de entender por qué el oro
extraído de sudáfrica pasó por mal y con
destino a bamako
en la capital de mali el jefe de aduanas
que contactamos no tuvo tiempo para
recibirnos entonces nos dirigimos hacia
el gran mercado a la dirección indicada
en la factura de la empresa sky gold
pero aquí nadie conocía esta empresa y
el número de teléfono no estaba
disponible
[Aplausos]
sin embargo la empresa existe
encontramos su certificado de registro
fue fundada en 2014 con un capital de un
millón de francos cf a una suma modesta
para hacer compras de más de dos mil
millones de francos efe a de oro
la dirección de sky goal que corresponde
al edificio a maridar fuimos hasta allí
pero al llegar el lugar parece
abandonado en todos los edificios de
este tipo en el gran mercado hay una
gran cantidad de pequeños comercios
es necesario adentrarse hasta el último
piso para encontrar locales de compra y
fundición de oro de manera excepcional
pudimos entrar a uno de ellos
después de pasar una requisa en la
entrada drum and que trabaja aquí desde
hace más de 10 años nos muestra las
instalaciones
[Música]
autónomo a todos
hola
cuando viene un cliente los recibimos
aquí
en la recepción con franja menos
se reciben pequeñas pepitas que vienen
de toda la subregión
este local compra los quilates en
función del peso y la calidad del oro el
gramo vale alrededor de 50 dólares
una pequeña fortuna en un país donde
pocas veces el salario supera los 100
dólares al mes
todos los días es así
incluso los domingos aquí vienen unas
100 personas pero llegan de todas partes
de malí y después están los que vienen
de costa de marfil de burkina también de
guinea
nos aseguran que el oro de malí es el
más valorado porque generalmente es de
mejor calidad que el de los países
vecinos
hay 101 gramos
también hay 617
hay 200 y otros así
después de la compra lo preparamos para
la fundición
el estado maliense tiene el monopolio de
la extracción de oro y también de la
exportación aquí no se puede hacer nada
sin el consentimiento de las autoridades
estas condiciones instaladas en los
techos de los grandes mercados de bamako
trabajan sobre todo con oro artesanal
que actualmente representa la mitad de
las exportaciones de mali una vez
mezcladas las pepitas se funden en
hornillos improvisados
nunca se podrá determinar con precisión
el origen del metal precioso que será
exportado al resto del mundo
[Música]
pese a la crisis político-militar que
causa estragos en mali el comercio del
oro ha tenido un auge sorprendente su
precio alcanzado récords históricos en
los últimos dos años y no es la guerra
lo que ha limitado de la producción sino
la pandemia de coronavirus que
desacelera la circulación de personas y
mercancías pero ahora los negocios se
han retomado
este fundidor asegura producir
diariamente entre 80 y 100 kilos de
lingotes lo que representa más de 5
millones de dólares al día
en bamako a veces pasa las personas se
aprovechan de la situación para extraer
oro y venir a venderlo
como dije antes el coronavirus lo ha
un poco
antes fundamos mucho más que eso
los lingotes producidos en seguida son
numerados en función de su peso y de la
pureza del oro que contiene
después de fundirlo lo traemos aquí él
también tiene que verificarlo
[Música]
en este local afirman enviar cargamentos
al extranjero todos los días a través
del aeropuerto de bamako
a dónde va a ser otra mano
[Música]
y
eso se recibe en dubai
sólo agua
miren esto también esto no vale un kilo
son 749
hace unos años el oro africano se
enviaba a suiza o sudáfrica pero
actualmente se encamina hacia dubai las
cifras son difíciles de verificar porque
las estadísticas de exportación de los
países africanos con destino a dubai no
tienen nada que ver con las estadísticas
de importación de los emiratos árabes
unidos- de lo que proviene del
continente
por ejemplo en 2019 valley declaró
exportar 500 kilos hacia dubai pero los
emiratos árabes unidos afirmaron haber
importado de ese mismo año más de 80
toneladas de oro provenientes de bamako
es muy posible que los lingotes de sky
gold que estaban destinados a uruguay
con tuvieron oro de malí legal o ilegal
e
en mali hay más de 350 zonas legales de
exportación minera pero a raíz de la
guerra la producción artesanal ilegal se
ha disparado obtuvimos estas imágenes
exclusivas de la mina ventaja acá a unos
50 kilómetros al suroeste de gao
[Música]
e
es la zona de extracción de oro más
grande en el norte de mali sobre decenas
de kilómetros los picos y los tamices
levantando este polvo
asoladas por las tormentas de arena en
estas minas las condiciones de trabajo
son deplorables al igual que en las
otras zonas de minería artesanal del
sahel aquí hay muchas nacionalidades
sudaneses nigerianos liberianos ghaneses
burkina a veces pero también libios o
sirios
la población de esta zona es imposible
de determinar pero sería superior a la
de la ciudad de gao que alberga más de
120 mil habitantes esta zona aislada
escapa del control del gobierno maliense
el marco estratégico permanente reúne a
los principales movimientos armados que
firmaron el acuerdo de argel la
coordinación de los movimientos de las
aguas que ellos garantizan la seguridad
de estos mineros pero los ataques
yihadistas pueden ocurrir en cualquier
momento
[Música]
los mineros que aceptaron contestar a
nuestras preguntas afirman que la
población antes era atacada y saqueada
con frecuencia pero ahora se siente lo
suficientemente protegida para trabajar
por abella
en esta zona de extracción de oro tiene
más de 23 años
la seguridad parece estar garantizada
las personas están en paz y seguras
cada uno hace lo mejor que puede ganamos
en función de lo que trabajamos de
nuestro esfuerzo y el material que
tengamos para trabajar
pero todas las personas que trabajan
aquí ganar al menos dos tres o cuatro
centímetros de oro al día yo trabajo
para mí mismo no trabajo para nadie las
personas que trabajan aquí reciben un
pago según los acuerdos establecidos por
los que ocupan el lugar
algunos mineros han ganado mucho dinero
porque los intermediarios con los que
trabajan reciben pedidos de oro
regulares y pagados de antemano
[Aplausos]
los compradores vienen de todas partes
de los países de los emiratos pero
recientemente también de turquía o rusia
nos reunimos con los líderes de los
movimientos de las aguas que controlan
la mina de oro de encaja acá cerca de
gau y las de la región de kidal en el
centro del país
el jefe de la delegación había vuelto de
una larga gira de 3000 kilómetros por el
país nos explica que para las
poblaciones del norte la explotación
artesanal del oro empezó a raíz de la
guerra y de las desilusiones frente a la
gobernanza de los estados del sahel
los estados el fondo monetario
internacional el banco mundial no sé la
ahogada la cedeao la oea no hablan por
esas poblaciones
han vivido las reglas del juego estados
reconocidos impuestos presupuestos
nacionales que se votan cada año leyes
financieras votadas pero no han visto el
impacto y los dividendos
cuando uno le pregunta a un buscador de
oro local que hace lo posible por
esquivar todos los peligros y que al
final logra sacar medio kilo de oro y
llega un ucraniano no sé por poner un
ejemplo un sahel ya no un estadounidense
da igual que sea yihadista judío del
hezbollah del fatah o de lo que usted
quiera
del kremlin si le aporta liquidez al
país en franco se fea se lo vende así es
como ven las cosas no hay que ir más
allá
garantizar la seguridad de estas zonas
no es tan fácil el 6 de diciembre de
2021 siete combatientes de la
coordinación de los movimientos de las
aguas fueron asesinados en inta jaca por
miembros del grupo estado islámico
para asegurar la protección de esos
mineros los miembros del meta planean
generalizar un impuesto de un 5 por
ciento sobre todas las ganancias de más
de un millón de francos cf ah
es decir unos 1500 dólares al mes pero
el representante del mes no sabe cuánto
recaudan los grupos jihadistas en las
zonas que controlan
es posible que los grupos yihadistas
obliguen a pagar impuestos en las zonas
que controlan en los comercios donde
tienen influencia
suelen ser anuales es una práctica
musulmana cuando al final del año se
tiene una cierta cantidad de bienes
se hace un cálculo con base en esos
bienes y se paga un porcentaje
y los yihadistas o los demás tampoco son
personas ingenuos son inteligentes como
todos nosotros puede ser que cada uno de
nosotros tenga una opinión sobre por qué
hacen todo eso pero ellos también
combinan el contexto político y las
necesidades económicas de las
poblaciones y
se adaptan
incluso en su forma de ser restrictivos
y de imponer reglas a veces se miden
porque detrás de todo eso hay una
economía detrás de todo eso hay
dividendos no para todos evidentemente
pero son lógicas cada vez más
desarrolladas
[Música]
en mali pero también en nigeria o en
burkina faso grupos armados han tomado
el control y desde 2016 se benefician de
las zonas de extracción de oro en las
áreas donde el estado es débil o está
ausente más de 5.000 millones de dólares
saldrían todos los años de estos tres
países
en forma de lingotes de oro una fuga
enorme y una pérdida de ingresos
importantes para los estados productores
esta fiebre del oro también es un factor
de inseguridad para las poblaciones en
este mapa de burkina faso aparecen en
negro las zonas auríferas artesanales y
en rojo la instalación progresiva de los
grupos yihadistas en los últimos tres
años la correlación es evidente
sí
[Música]
la explotación anárquica del oro se ha
extendido a toda la región porque las
fronteras son porosas
[Música]
miles de carreteras permiten pasar de un
país al otro muchos traficantes circulan
en moto y pasan desapercibidos
así es como la desestabilización
regional del comercio del oro se ha
extendido a los países ubicados más al
sur
nos dirigimos a tendré la una pequeña
localidad marfileña en la frontera con
mali porque el oro de sky gold también
podría venir de la costa de marfil el
séptimo productor de oro del continente
[Música]
entre la el oro es una fuente importante
de ingresos cada semana salen entre 8 y
10 kilos de esta pequeña localidad la
mayoría de las minas están en la
subprefectura de para para pudimos
entrar a una de las pocas minas
artesanales legales del norte del país
estos mineros se organizaron en una
cooperativa la zona abarca 25 hectáreas
los excavadores vienen aquí de todas
partes de la región apenas se encuentra
un hueco queda oro llegan cientos de
jóvenes dicen que antes de la guerra
trabajaban en los campos con sus padres
en los últimos 10 años las actividades
de estos pueblos han cambiado
radicalmente
en fin decirle lo como
ah
a
hay asador
alcalá
me llamo califa
soy buscador de oro
ahora este es mi oficio en realidad si
es dios el que decide lo que vamos a
encontrar
y
nosotros nunca sabemos si vamos a ganar
algo cuando bajamos al hueco
vamos a parar
a
la búsqueda de oro ahora hace parte de
la economía de estos pueblos en el norte
de costa de marfil todos participan los
miembros de la cooperativa la asociación
de jóvenes la asociación de mujeres para
este militar retirado que ahora dirige
la cooperativa el oro contribuye al
desarrollo local
la población obtiene beneficios pero si
estuviera en la clandestinidad no
ayudamos al pueblo la cooperativa ayudo
a la escuela de para para
gastamos casi 20 millones para construir
un aula digital y un comedor para la
escuela
construimos un comedor para la escuela
primaria encontramos material sanitario
para el hospital
incluso pagamos una moto para el
hospital
para que hiciera los desplazamientos
cortos porque antes ni siquiera tenían
una ambulancia
esa ha sido un poco la contribución
los responsables de esta mina están un
poco preocupados por su seguridad
les gustaría solo emplear marfileños
para evitar las infiltraciones de
yihadistas pero en esta región hay tanta
movilidad poblacional que ese objetivo
es imposible de mantener
entonces la mina es supervisada por los
dos
está fraternidad de cazadores
tradicionales brinda apoyo a las fuerzas
del orden en estos pueblos remotos del
norte del país
[Música]
todo el mundo es requisado tanto a la
entrada como a la salida de la mina
[Música]
acaban de interceptar a un minero
maliense le piden que muestre sus
papeles
a la sansi sé correcto
hablo con adam a traoré
tome sus cosas y vaya si no nuestra
oreja
tenemos que identificar debe tener algún
pariente seguro que nos diga si está
conmigo porque es mal y en
para que diga que es su tutor si no
tiene el tutor la cooperativa lo llevará
ante la brigada para que lo interroguen
los miembros de esta cooperativa
explican que también trabajan con los
líderes de los pueblos valientes y
burkina a veces que bordean la frontera
porque es muy posible que el oro de tela
se venda fuera de costa de marfil el
dinamismo del sector está vinculado a la
historia de la región
la extracción de oro en el norte del
país está ligada a la guerra civil ya la
ocupación de esas zonas por los nuevos
esfuerzos
los movimientos rebeldes que llevaron a
las a no atar al poder en 2010 durante
la guerra se explotaba ahora en la
región
según este consultor que ha trabajado
para varias organizaciones
internacionales el tráfico actual se
inscribe en la continuidad de esa
historia militar
durante la época de la rebelión en un
momento fue necesario el alimento
[Música]
eran soldados pero no eran soldados
profesionales eran gente que había sido
reclutada y que podía hacer un trabajo
duro y
llegó un punto en el que había que
alimentarla había que pagar el
equipamiento había que sobrevivir
y encontraron una fuente de financiación
que era la explotación aurífera
artesanal
pero como no podían negociar con las
oficinas legales de compra y venta de
oro que estaban en abiyán
en la parte gubernamental fue necesario
recurrir a otras fuentes de financiación
en los países limítrofes como malí y
burkina
[Música]
que tienen una larga cultura de
extracción de oro tenían sistemas que
funcionaban muy bien que estaban
establecidos y tenían compradores
pero los factores históricos no bastan
para explicar por qué bamako se ha
establecido como el principal centro de
compra de oro de los países argelia nos
los impuestos a la exportación son
bastante más bajos que en los países
vecinos
3% y solo sobre los primeros 50 kilos de
oro pero no siempre en la factura de sky
gold se ve claramente que quienes
transportaron el oro sólo pagaron cinco
mil francos cf a menos de diez euros por
todo el cargamento
sin embargo en bamako no todos los
actores del sector están satisfechos con
la situación
en cancún usa una de las dos refinerías
industriales de la capital maliense el
jefe está bastante preocupado
este empresario ítalo suizo que vive en
el país desde hace más de 20 años no ha
podido llevar a cabo su proyecto
en 2014 invirtió más de 6 millones de
dólares en esta fábrica que permite
fundir lingotes de oro puros con eso
esperaba poder recuperar gran parte de
la producción maliense y también la de
los países vecinos
por un lado estamos muy desanimados
siendo honesto benítez
la refinería no llega ni al 10% de su
capacidad
[Música]
aunque las fábricas de fundición del
gran mercado funcionan a todo marcha
esta refinería no recibe suficiente
materia prima para sus instalaciones
totalmente nuevas esta empresa que
exporta suiza en eeuu le interesa poco a
los buscadores de oro locales
nadie quiere lidiar con las complejas
regulaciones de los países occidentales
los negocios son mucho más sencillos en
dubai
efe
[Música]
le preguntamos a dario si conocía a la
empresa sky gold y le mostramos la
fotografía de los lingotes
pero van dijk puerto
es ahora en bruto sí
es oro que tiene diferentes quilates
tiene un componente de oro dentro
[Música]
con un porcentaje diferente entre cada
lingote y también tiene otros metales
preciosos contiene plata plata blanca
contiene platino en algunos casos
contiene paladio dubai quiere ese oro
bajo esa forma porque las refinerías de
dubai viven y ganan por los otros
metales son gratuitos
imagínense 60 toneladas de oro en bruto
al año en dubai eso significa entre 5 y
6 toneladas de plata gratis al año eso
sí que es una economía sin economía
eso
para saber de dónde viene el oro the sky
gold dario nos aconseja hablar con su
técnico de laboratorio nos explica que
al identificar los metales asociados al
oro en teoría sería posible tener una
idea del origen de los lingotes pero el
ejercicio es complejo porque habría que
tener una base de datos de los
componentes geológicos de todas las
minas que hay en todas las regiones del
mundo en esta refinería se suelen
separar los metales preciosos del oro en
bruto para los clientes y en mali se
recupera sobre todo plata blanca común y
lamenta las exportaciones masivas hacia
dubai es una pérdida de ingresos para
las industrias del país africano
tenemos que ser conscientes de ese
fenómeno y crear valor agregado
porque cuando logramos transformar
nuestras materias primas aquí
los clientes que quieran otro vendrán a
invertir en infraestructuras como esta
refinería
puede haber muchas otras refinerías en
mali
esto va a crear muchos más empleos para
los jóvenes como yo que no tienen
trabajo
y hay muchas otras cosas que vienen con
ese producto interno bruto del país va a
aumentar
mantén
pero dario tiene otro proyecto especial
para vender ahora perfectamente
rastreable planea construir centros de
acopio y servicio para los mineros
artesanales 15 centros de este tipo
deberían haberse abierto en 2022 si la
situación de seguridad no hubiese
permitido
nuestra misión en el país es lograr
tener un oro rastreable 100% rastreable
hasta el punto de conocer las
características los nombres y los
apellidos de la persona que lo produjo y
una idea acorde con las recomendaciones
de organismos como la ocde al supervisar
la cadena de abastecimiento se
desarrollan las comunidades mineras y se
reduce la contribución del oro al
financiamiento de los conflictos es un
escenario ideal pero la situación que
predomina actualmente en las zonas
mineras es muy diferente a los 73 kilos
que se encontraron en sudáfrica dan risa
en suiza en 2019 confiscaron 24
toneladas de oro provenientes de dubai
cuyo origen no fue declarado 24
toneladas pero entró a suiza para ir a
las distintas refinerías de la lma de
24 toneladas 173 kilos a mí no me gusta
mucho
si quiero que mi refinería tenga una
buena reputación y tenga futuro como
infraestructura con un buen nombre tengo
que evitar a dubai
[Música]
y el libro the sky world estaba
destinado a dubai era por pura comodidad
es perfectamente legal llevar lingotes
en las maletas y el transporte de oro en
las maletas de mano se ha convertido en
uno de los mejores métodos para importar
oro ilegal a los emiratos árabes unidos
llamada la ciudad del oro en los últimos
años esta megalópolis se ha vuelto un
eje central del comercio internacional
del oro
y
[Música]
las autoridades han convertido el metal
amarillo en un pilar de su economía pero
también de su turismo para
imprescindible para los visitantes el
principal foco del oro situado en el
barrio histórico de beira hay lingotes y
joyas de todas las formas y colores
también se puede vender fácilmente el
oro propio
aquí todo brilla incluso el azafrán que
proviene de irán se guarda en
recipientes dorados el oro the sky gold
estaba destinado a dubai a la empresa
propia ubicada justo en frente del
edificio del centro del oro fuimos hasta
allí
en la esquina de una calle de la ciudad
vieja menos turística party gold todavía
está activa aunque tratamos de
contactarlos varias veces los
responsables nunca nos contestaron un
año después del caso de los 73 kilos de
oro en enero de 2021 la empresa volvió a
estar implicada en otro tráfico de casi
50 kilos de oro esta vez a través de
cómodas
le estaba comprando oro a otra empresa
registrada en mali llamada malí metal el
esquema es sospechosamente similar a la
anterior unos contrabandistas malgaches
y bueno hacia dubai con facturas de malí
en 2018 los emiratos árabes unidos-
importaron 50 toneladas de oro
provenientes de áfrica en 2020 la cifra
ascendió a 500 toneladas en menos de
cinco años los emiratos multiplicaron
por día sus importaciones provenientes
del continente africano pero los
consumidores que hacen sus compras en el
zoco del oro se preocupa un poco por su
origen en las vitrinas se exhiben
lingotes suizos y los vendedores
explican que el oro simplemente es
reciclado en tu baile
el oro es más barato aquí hay muchas
tiendas por eso tantas personas vienen a
comprar oro en dubai
importamos el oro de suiza sudáfrica ha
reunido
importamos oro puro y fabricamos las
joyas de aquí
más de 4000 empresas trabajan en el
sector del oro en dubai el sistema
fiscal tiene ventajas porque aquí no se
pagan impuestos corporativos ni sobre
los ingresos para salir de la
dependencia del petróleo y convertirse
en un centro del comercio los emiratos
árabes unidos- establecieron 45 son las
francas
es
el de msc centro de negocios para
materias primas fue creado en 2002 con
68 torres y 200 hectáreas es la zona
franca más grande de los emiratos el
sector del oro es una de sus actividades
principales el dms se estableció órganos
para promoverlo pero también para
regularlo el conflicto de intereses es
evidente
a pesar de nuestros esfuerzos tanto en
el de msc como en el gobierno nadie
aceptó hablar con nosotros nos reunimos
entonces con un investigador suizo que
trabaja desde hace varios años en
demostrar que el oro sucio de las zonas
de conflicto es blanqueado en dubai su
informe abarca alrededor de 50 estados
africanos
los controles son extremadamente laxos
en el aeropuerto de dubai es decir que
si uno llega con su equipaje de mano si
obviamente tiene que presentar un
certificado de la misma factura ni
siquiera está obligado a mostrar el
certificado de libros simplemente se
puede pagar una multa todas las personas
en el soplo de fórum dicen lo mismo no
hay ningún problema para pasar las
aduanas se puede falsificar fácilmente
un certificado el origen
solamente hay que mostrar el pasaporte
actualmente si uno se fija en los países
donde hay conflictos bien sea la
república democrática es como burkina
faso malí níger no sólo
el oro de esos países siempre terminan
dubai por un lado directamente y por
otro indirectamente por ejemplo el boro
de la república democrática del congo
finalmente pasan por banda banda después
terminando white
lo mismo pasa con el oro del norte de
burkina faso las zonas de conflicto
realmente pasa por el mayo antes de ser
exportado
[Música]
entonces dubai realmente es la lavadora
del muro problemático de áfrica que a
menudo proviene de las zonas de
conflictos
es difícil saber la cantidad exacta de
refinerías que hay en dubai pero una vez
refinado el origen del oro es imposible
de rastrear físicamente así que las
refinerías tienen una responsabilidad
particular en la cadena de
abastecimiento
algunas personas nos decían pero que van
a ir a investigar en los emiratos árabes
unidos
de todas maneras solo es oro reciclado y
el problema del oro reciclado es que
incluye todo
puede ser uno de los nazis puede ser oro
de un tesoro de hace doscientos años
varios informes han denunciado la falta
de medidas destinadas a regular el
comercio de oro en dubai en 2019 un
informe del grupo de expertos de la onu
la aumentaba que no se hubiera incautado
el oro contrabandeado en 2020 el gafi el
organismo intergubernamental contra el
blanqueamiento de dinero y la
financiación del terrorismo
alertó a dubai acerca de los riesgos del
blanqueamiento de dinero
y en marzo de 2022 el gafi incluyó a los
emiratos árabes unidos- en su lista gris
en sudáfrica el caso de los traficantes
malgaches sigue abierto la empresa sky
gold que no había contestado a los
llamados de la justicia sudafricana
finalmente dio señales de vida al cabo
de un año de proceso judicial
los responsables de parp ya la empresa
de uruguay quieren recuperar a toda
costa la mercancía que compraron el
gobierno de madagascar también quiere
quedarse con el oro pero nadie ha podido
probar la procedencia de los lingotes
la historia de este fraude aduanero
valorado en unos 3 millones de dólares
es tan sólo la punta del iceberg una
gota de agua en un comercio
internacional que asciende a miles de
millones de dólares no tiene ocupados a
los policías del mundo entero y alimenta
a más de 40 millones de mineros
artesanales además de los traficantes
que con cada viaje corren el riesgo de
ser condenados a varios años de prisión
los excavadores suelen ser los únicos
capturados en los circuitos criminales
desde sudáfrica hasta malí ellos son los
primeros eslabones de este tráfico pero
seguirán alimentando la cadena de
abastecimiento saciando la sed por el
oro en los cinco continentes
[Música]